Speaker 1: Sarah Palin is running for Congress.
Sarah Palin is the for our younger viewers. She
was the sort of precursor to the Trump types. This
is this is actually a really interesting political
history moment. Bush, George W. Bush was kind of
dim, and the thing about him is he's not really
all of it led to Trump, but he's not really
the pre-Trump mold in the sense that he was
actually a neocon. Bush was a neocon. Palin was
kind of the first what I call sort of like dumb
con, where it's like the main thing is you don't
know anything. With Bush, he didn't know much,
but he was still a neocon at heart. Palin was
the first sliver of what eventually was Trump
and Trumpism, which is they're just clueless
reactionaries, lacking any real ideology. And
she was the late John McCain's running mate in
2008. They fortunately lost to Barack Obama,
and she is now running for Congress. Sarah Palin
files to run for the late Alaska representative
Don Young's seat. Sarah Palin filed with
the FEC on Friday for the special election.
She said America is at a tipping point. As
I've watched the far left destroy the country,
I knew I had to step up and join the fight. Palin
filed an hour before Friday's filing deadline.
There are 50 candidates in the field, so
for will have plenty of time to talk about
Sarah Palin more. But for those who maybe
don't remember her, she was known for the word
salad before Trump perfected it. Here's one
example from an interview in 2016 with Jake
Tapper, a visibly disoriented Sarah Palin here.
Speaker 5: You talked about inconsistencies among
the votes and the positions of Senator
Cruz. Donald Trump is somebody who has
clearly had different positions on issues that
he has today, including an issue very near
and dear to your heart. The issue of abortion
and life, right? Have you talked to him about
that he used to be? He called himself very
pro-choice. Now he says, he's very pro-life.
Speaker 3: I am so glad that Mr. Trump has seen
the light and understands the sanctity of innocent
life and how a baby in the womb should be most
protected. What has been kind of sad about the
situation, though, politically speaking, are
groups that are pro-life and want it. They
say they want to bring more people into the fold.
They given Trump a hard time for his past views on
abortion, where they're celebrating others like
I was going through a list like Justin Bieber.
What? And gosh, Bieber? Yeah, yeah, who has made
Speaker 1: that that this is Jake Tapper's best
moment where he looks perplexed and goes.
Justin Bieber. Yeah, I don't know, either.
Speaker 3: Jake understanding the sanctity of
life, but in the past said he was no big deal
to him, you know, and he's just one example.
But I've heard this same group celebrate people
who have been to their fundraisers. I've spoken
at their events and there's usually someone in
the crowd. Every single one of these crowds
who will testify to having seen the light,
you know, to understand, Oh, I guess, yeah.
Speaker 1: So I'm really hoping that she
does some debates. Here's one more
example again, for our young viewers,
here is Sarah Palin speaking at a Trump event and
really just an incredible word salad. Immigrants,
welcome in. This is like a chop chop.
They've really chopped it all up,
and it's just like confetti
Speaker 3: them in even inducing
and seducing them with gift baskets. Come on
over the border in here, the gift basket of
teddy bears and soccer balls, our kids and our
grandkids, they'll never know then what it is
to be rewarded for that entrepreneurial spirit
that God creates within us in order to work and
to produce and to strive and to thrive and to
really be alive. Wisconsin Reagan saved the hog
here. You're Harley Davidson. That was Reagan.
Speaker 1: It made as little sense then as it
does now, and we can only hope that Sarah
Palin will be participating in debates. So
Sarah Palin is running another notable race in
2020. Much ahead when it comes to the midterms.